Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with news about a recurring and
strange phenomenon anti-muslim hate
crimes that turn out to be nothing of
the kind this one was especially
egregious and heartbreaking or at least
that's the way it seemed at first The
Huffington Post headlined Its story
islamophobia just drove this boy and his
family out of America the Huff po story
was heartbreaking indeed it began this
way I'm done with the US zishan alhassan
usman's wife told him on Friday seeing
her youngest son just 7 years old walk
off the school bus bruised and battered
that afternoon outside their apartment
building and carry North Carolina was
the final straw The Huffington Post
story went on this way little abdulaziz
a first grader and the youngest child of
usmani and Benes bagwani was traumatized
he told his parents a classmate had Tri
to force him to eat food that wasn't
Halal when abdulaziz refused five of his
classmates ganged up on him making fun
of his name then they punched him in the
face kicked him in the stomach and
twisted his arm while calling him Muslim
again and again usmani said horrible
story right there's just one catch none
of this really happened if usman's claim
were true that they keep beating him all
the way from school to home on the bus
the boy would have suffered extensive
injuries and the bus would have been an
an uproar as anyone who's ever ridden on
a school bus knows instead after an
investigation school officials announced
no students who were interviewed
witnessed an altercation the bus driver
did not witness an altercation the child
did not report to the bus driver any
injury now I don't know how far young
abdulaziz lives away from school but in
a photo of him that was released after
the supposed attack the boy does not
look anything like the description that
his mother gave of him being bruised and
battered he has his arm in a sling but
otherwise looks happily unscathed he
hardly looks like a boy who's just been
beaten all the way home from school no
facial marks whatsoever Nar a bruise no
black eye no fat lip nothing the bullies
were strikingly ineffectual if that is
they existed at all and it looks as if
they didn't so here we go again hate
crimes are political Capital when real
ones don't exist they must be invented
Hamas link care and other Muslims have
on many occasions not hesitated to stoop
even to fabricating hate crimes
including attacks on mosques a New
Jersey Muslim was recently found guilty
of murder that he at first had tried to
portray as an islamophobic attack and in
2014 in California a Muslim was found
guilty of killing his wife after first
blaming her murder on
islamophobia this kind of thing happens
quite frequently the New York daily news
recently reported that quote a woman who
told cops she was called a terrorist and
slashed on her cheek in lower Manhattan
on Thursday later admitted she made up
the story police said early Friday the
woman who wore a head scarf told
authorities a blade wielding wacko
sliced open her face as she left a
Manhattan cosmetology school police
sources said and recently in Britain the
murder of a popular Imam was spread far
and wide as another islamophobic hate
crime until his killer was also found to
be a Muslim the mirror reported that the
Imam was targeted because had made
efforts to turn youngsters away from
radical
Islam according to the Detroit News
recently a Muslim woman SAA chatty was
charged with making a false police
report after she allegedly fabricated a
plot to blow up Dearborn Fordson High
School to retaliate against the November
terrorist attacks in Paris Police say
chatty called Dearborn investigators
November 19th 2015 6 days after Islamic
extremists killed 130 people in Paris
similar in Britain a Muslim woman was
fined for lying to police about being
attacked for wearing a hijab the
18-year-old student known only as Miss
chowder said she was violently shoved
from behind and punched in the face by a
man in Birmingham city center 10 days
after the atrocities in the French
capital on November
13th yet despite school officials
findings in the case of young abdulaziz
usmani watch for this one also to show
up in the hate crimes list of the Hamas
link Council on American Islamic
relations it's what they do I'm Robert
Spencer